so then when i you know became an adult
and i started making a little bit of
money on youtube they were like okay
you can talk to our lawyer now who
turned out to be a financial advisor so
i was like okay
um i don't know what to do with this
money please help me because otherwise
it's just gonna collect in a bank
probably do [ __ ] nothing and he's
like well you could you know
mortgage and i'm like that would i
i don't know that word ideally anyone
with any kind of savings would have a
financial advisor sadly you know
you know it's kind of difficult to get a
good one or get one that even you know
like understand yeah yeah i mean yeah i
had to [ __ ] i wouldn't i would if i
could i mean i don't [ __ ] know anyone
no i had to sit our like guy down to be
like okay this is what i do
and he was like wait so you make videos
and you get paid to do that
now like yeah and he's like okay yeah i
mean
i would love a financial advisor because
i there's like like there's so
little i know about it and this this
kind of this you know the
wall street's bets thing that's been
going on has really just opened my eyes
to
how little i know about this stuff that
i feel like i really should know
yeah yeah like a youtuber i've been
watching recently is a guy called i
think it's graham
specter i think who you are yeah the
millionaire guy who's
like i saw him in like other videos
where he was talking about
it's it's he he seems like the most
grounded millionaire i've
ever you know i couldn't stand him at
first he seemed like a dick
and then i started watching him i was
like all right okay he's pretty cool but
he just came off as like an ass no
because
like the biggest thing that puts me off
is every episode he goes he does the
but don't forget to like and subscribe
if you like the video and
like no matter how cool a person you are
if you say it immediately ironically it
just like
like yeah immediate turn off but like i
was watching some of the videos and some
of the
advice that he he gave which was some of
it was like just like
really basic financial advice about how
to like manage your money
and this the thing is he he gives advice
that
any person from any level of income can
can like um
can take to heart because uh like one of
the ideas that he
really tried to propagate is like no
matter how much
earned you can you can all everyone
should get into the mindset well that
you can invest something yeah that's
that's
what that's what i because i i'd grown
up with the mindset of like
people the word investment that's for
rich people that's for privileged people
i
i can't invest i don't have the money to
invest but even just investing
like a fraction of your paycheck or
something
in the long term can really help you
financially and give you a lot of
financial stability and
this this is the stuff that we just we
were just never taught
i guess as well because you've heard so
many horror stories about investments
going wrong and you also hear about like
you know people who take advantage of
people with like you know
find a fake financial advisor who says
i'll help you out with your money and
then
just runs off with it right yeah yeah
exactly it's so scary to trust someone
with any amount of money
yeah and you know if even if you have
like barely anything
it's still all you have right it's scary
to give that to somebody yeah yeah like
oh i trust you
to take care of this right because
because the way that i was taught up
because uh you know i
i also didn't come from like the most
willow family so
you didn't have a lawyer or a finance i
didn't i don't know i did not have a
family financially
i just gave joey's parents i thought
everyone had one of those i mean my
parents
my parents declared like bankruptcy when
i was a teenager it was you know it's oh
[ __ ]
yeah so you know i was taught i was like
i grew up with the mentality that you
know you should try to keep your money
safe you should you know gather up as
much as possible and i realized
how much this mentality had affected how
i think about
just resources in general so what when
what i realized is that
i'm that gamer right i am that gamer who
whenever you know
when whenever you play an rpg you don't
use anything and you get you get it you
get a rare item
i don't use it i don't use it and
whenever i play like command and conquer
or something or some
rts games right i wait until i have a
[ __ ] ton of resources
and then i start buying stuff out and i
realized i realized this
this week when i when i was like where
did this come from and i realized oh
it's because that's just how i manage my
money and that's just
i i've always come in the mindset of
i've got to save this just in case of a
rainy day i can't invest it
i need to save it because you know
investing money might be
risky so it's better to just save it and
you know i i kind of realized this as i
was doing research and i
learned a lot about myself uh this past
week because of a [ __ ] meme
because because a lot of like
entrepreneurs are like spending
everything they have like just goes like
right into buying [ __ ] like they have
like no
savings it's just all the businesses
that's all just high risk high rewards
yeah but then also as well you know
online there's so much of those fake
stupid entrepreneurs
online they've just really like ruined
in my mind the image of an entrepreneur
dude speed run ruining like five years
dude
if i go on like a twitter or a social
media and it has the word entrepreneur
on it
right you know two years ago yeah
entrepreneur was probably one of the
coolest things you could say
yeah you're an entrepreneur now i just
think oh you're just doing a [ __ ]
multi-level marketing scam to me
oh you're selling me a course on how to
be more confident have you seen those
courses yeah
those things are insane they cost like
it's like 1k for the first course and
then they're like
all right now you've unlocked the
ability to get the next level of the
course for only five thousand dollars
and it blows my mind
they're like trying to teach you [ __ ]
that can't be learned yeah it but it
blows my mind that that people
buy into this stuff because they're
obviously just people who have who are
spending the money you're giving them
on this lavish lifestyle but then they
sell back to you like
it's insane and i don't know how people
get sucked into this like
with like when we're talking about the
gambling stuff i can understand how
somebody can get into gambling and
gamble away
i don't understand how someone can watch
these entrepreneurs right these fake
entrepreneurs talk about how
they can make you loads of money and
they can tell you how to be like there's
loads like real
realtors have you seen those yeah yeah
like i could teach you
the best real estate course of your life
just come here for a hundred dollars and
then
have someone else take [ __ ] and then
have five more classes i'm like how does
someone believe this [ __ ]
it's all fake obviously i don't get it i
mean someone believes the [ __ ] because
there's i think the biggest problem is
that there's
so much information out there right now
that
you don't know who to believe you know
you just gotta
i mean i i can see when someone knows
nothing about
yeah i i know nothing about many things
yeah but i also know when someone's
chatting out of them no no
you know what i mean you know you you
have you have a [ __ ] detective
yeah a lot of people don't have a 500
pay wall right out the gate for a lesson
is normally the first indication of
i think to a lot of people you know they
see that pay wall and they see the
presentation they think oh well this is
probably legit yeah i mean i'm putting
money into this so that must
this much for this course then it must
bring results yeah maybe yeah maybe i
just can't see that because obviously
we're doing like entertainment
yeah we've been on the internet for long
enough to know what's going on
we're producing content i know i know
what fake content looks like right i
know i can imagine how it was made
yeah exactly yeah because whenever i
swipe
whenever i see one of those like
marketing um
trailers of like oh you can learn x
amount and earn x amount i swear they
they all have the same [ __ ] templates
and with the same
inspiring stock the first music i made
three thousand dollars
the next month after that i made one
million dollars
and it's like oh i'm sure you did i'm
sure you did
off off mugging everyone off yeah
exactly it's like it's it's like the
equivalent of going on a piracy site and
then seeing the
adverts of i earned ten thousand dollars
from filling out
surveys and you're like who the [ __ ]
actually clicks on this and believes
this stuff
it is it is it is they call it all like
porn ads right
the fact that you're advertising on like
not even pornhub or like
some shady hentai website this pill and
your dick will go
three times the size in three months it
must i don't think about it more must
come from
like targeting insecurities right like
absolutely yeah like
some people are pretty insecure about
their financial amount yeah like
absolutely i'm sure there's other things
like that i mean i just realized now
why would they offer dick pills oh
because people are pretty insecure about
their dicks like looking right
yeah that's probably the same kind of
yeah and they probably and they don't
know any better right they just think
like well i want just the quickest
easiest like most straightforward way to
get a lot of money oh look at this ad
it's a harsh lesson in life to learn
that miracles truly don't exist
yeah yeah i mean i mean it's i'm sure
it's like that you need to actually put
the
work and effort into it that might just
be that might be a lifelong yes
i don't think any amount of pills is
going to save you only so many times you
can pop that bag
yeah exactly exactly no i mean i feel
like it's the same reason why people
fall for
multi-level marketing scams apparently
this is really bad in the us i have a
lot of friends from the us who tell me
that they know
they've met loads of their friends from
high school who tell them that
constantly messaged him about really
yeah yeah yeah
i i don't know how bad it is because i'm
connected to strange people who have
strange friends but
meline do you have friends who are
multi-level marketing people you do
alkaline water
ladies and gentlemen i have one case my
proof is there
i mean yeah i know a few people from
america as well you do
yeah maybe not like directly but you
know people yeah
i know people and even i think sydney's
mom has like
on an off occasion message sydney about
this
you know nice little scheme that can
make her money but
you know seeing the obviously like steps
in and it's because i mean it it
really preys on people who are looking
for that out
looking for that out in their life that
you know you when you're stuck at a
dead-end job
and you are you're old enough where you
feel like
you're kind of stuck here you're not
young enough to do something crazy or
just quit everything
and you have responsibilities you know
you kind of look for a way
that can that can that can get you out
of this lifestyle whatever that is and
sometimes i mean that's why that's why
it's that's
don't get me wrong
in order to like get out of that kind of
stuff like risk taking is definitely
a thing that you have to do but there's
risk-taking there's making mistakes
right
there's responsible risk-taking where
you'll always have a fallback if it
doesn't work out and then there's just a
risk take where you just yolo it yeah at
the end of the day
right the let's be honest right the way
life works if somebody had a million
dollar idea
yeah right a stranger isn't going to
come up to you and pitch it to you right
they're going to [ __ ] do it
themselves yeah exactly right like
if anyone comes up to you promising to
make you money that should be the
biggest red flag
in existence nobody nobody can promise
to make you money yeah
for for example if if that person also
promising to make you that money is
a billionaire themselves why the [ __ ]
aren't they doing it yeah exactly
exactly which is when i realized where
like you know when
what i've realized growing up is you
know my my mom and dad would give me you
know advice
about how to be successful in x and why
and i love my mom and dad
but then i came to a point when i
realized that some of the mentality
especially when managing money was
was not wrong per se because that's what
that's the mentality that they had
to survive because that's the
environment it was just different yeah
it was a different environment and i got
to realize
i'm growing up under different
circumstances and i have to
you know i have to choose sometimes
whenever some advice does pertain to me
and when it's when it doesn't and when
someone's
promising you to make money that's like
okay we're three successful youtubers
right but as much as as much advice as
we can give
we can not promise a random person to
make them a successful youtuber right
we can give advice about how to increase
their chances and how to
you know how to help work the algorithm
for example but we're not going to drop
like a million dollar video idea because
we would just do that there's no way
there's no way that i can sit here and
guarantee you that yes
i can give you advice to make you a
youtuber that gets a million subscribers
nobody can do that
or earn x amount from you as far as i'm
concerned we were all very lucky in that
case as well right we had like we had
the we had the odds in our favor but
yeah
it was but nobody taught us or like told
us what to do i mean like i
i i preach by that you know uh
we we did we did a lot of things right
uh and
we all were also very lucky in a lot of
aspects there wasn't
there wasn't one without the other um
there are things that you can do
to increase your chances of success and
massively
get the odds into your favor but to
guarantee something to guarantee success
like that it's
pretty much impossible yeah i think the
the
sad truth of life is that you just
realize this is like i think the stock
market looks like a [ __ ] casino too
many people and
i thought it was a lot a lot of the
hedge funds do treat it likes archie
yeah exactly
we learned that we learned that at the
end of the day
it's truly a sad moment when you realize
there isn't really a get-rich-quick
scheme in life it doesn't exist
right and like if you're looking for
that i feel like you're already setting
yourself up to be disappointed or
organized if there was a scheme that
could 100 percent
give you like a success rate of like
you're gonna get famous
you wouldn't think everybody would be
doing that it might make someone rich
probably not gonna be you
yeah okay like here's the thing like
do it like reading up about a lot of
like financial advice and everything
that i have
for the past you know the past week so
this is this is
like take this with an exact this is
actually three people who don't know
what the [ __ ] they're talking about
financial discuss financially
yeah exactly okay we do not take any of
our advice yeah
we do have to make a disclaimer about
this but from what i've read and from
what i've seen it's it seems like
you know you you can definitely increase
your chances of you know
being successful in life but the problem
is that a lot of
a lot of the i love the legitimate
advice i've seen
it seems to stem from uh you don't get
rich quick it's all boring stuff
it's all put your money in safe places
it's the last game wait
wait 10 to 20 years and you'll be well
off in life and nobody wants to hear
that advice that's just
boring that shit's boring they want to
hear the i
went to sleep woke up and i have a
million dollars now right you don't want
to hear about [ __ ] rough iras or put
your
put your money in [ __ ] cash i want a
game stop oh
they want to hear something exciting but
when you hear like boring financial
advice you just kind of tune out and
you're like oh okay
so i can get rich but just not now but
like in
10 20 no no no more like when i retire
i'm gonna have a retirement
fund and that's gone figured out why all
the old people hold all the wealth in
nearly every
developed country yeah why because i
noticed right when i was i i was just
looking around for maybe like i wanted
to just talk to about financial advisors
not like do anything
i just wanted to talk to them yeah and
just have like the free consultations
and talk to them just figure out what
the [ __ ]
like what do they do what can they do
what's a good one what's a bad one yeah
i noticed on all of the websites at
least in the uk every single one
right was just like it was picture of
some some young man
helping an old person out on a laptop
pointing at the monitor like
and then it was all stalking yeah it was
it was like oh
it was all just like pension advice
pension pension pension and like
long term long term like none of it was
like risky
yeah none of it was for young people
because yeah because you know let's be
honest
young people don't don't do that don't
do that no no
um so yeah it was just it was really you
kind of just like a lot of the things
that you'd noticed about the world
started to fall in place when you start
looking you're like
ah okay everything's starting to make
sense now yeah yeah
right yeah like my best advice to anyone
young watching this
is um if if this conversation leads to
anything just
go out and do your research actually
read up about this [ __ ] because i i
don't [ __ ] sign up to a 500 no no i
will [ __ ] i will disown you don't
don't do that just read up
about basic financial advice everything
you need to know is free
every yeah that's the thing everything
you need to know is free and the only
thing stopping you
is your own laziness because that's that
is me reading
me reading up about this felt like i had
just gained five levels of
of info that i should have known when i
was in my 20s and i'm just like why why
didn't i know this [ __ ] before i i was
stupid i was lazy
and don't expect to get rich off the
[ __ ] gamestop stonks and sure they're
like
the road is going to be long and
probably really boring yeah i'm
interesting and learning japanese so
that i can become a translator
for yakuza and then i'll translate the
wrong number liking the great pretender
and profit
hundreds of millions of dollars for
myself thus being the best investment
of ever well someone's going to take
that
[ __ ] steal my garbage quick idea i
swear to god you gave away the million
dollar idea bilingual
people don't do it all right yeah i'm
just like writing it joey's like [ __ ]
write that down
joey's call up his financial advisor
said this you won't believe it does
anyone know any arkansas
any yakuza with cross cross country gang
information
does anyone need any translation i'm
your man